president Trump's former lawyer Jenna
Ellis who defended the president during
his efforts to expose fraud in the 2020
election has accepted a plea deal and
agreed to cooperate with the government
in the ongoing trials against Trump and
his associates as an attorney who is
also a Christian I take my
responsibilities as a lawyer very
seriously and I Endeavor to be a person
of sound moral and ethical character in
all of my dealings in the wake of the
2020 presidential election
I believed that challenging the results
on behalf of President Trump should be
pursued in a just and legal way I
endeavored to represent my client to the
best of my ability I relied on others
including lawyers with many more years
of experience than I to provide me with
true and reliable information especially
since my role involved speaking to the
media and to legislators in various
States what I did not do but should have
done your honor was to make sure that
the facts the other lawyers alleged to
be true were in fact true in the
frenetic pace of attempting to raise
challenges to the election in several
States including Georgia I failed to do
my due diligence I believe in and I
value election Integrity if I knew then
what I know now I would have declined to
represent Donald Trump in these
post-election challenges I look back on
this whole experience with deep
remorse this is a very sad scene not
even just for Jenna regular regular
viewers and listeners to this show know
that Jenna is a friend of mine of quite
some years now and she's appeared many
times on this show including immediately
after she was indicted what is sad is
not even that she took some deal or
other that she pled guilty to some minor
offense in this case just one count of
quote aiding and abetting false
statements a far cry from the RICO
charges that the Georgia da is
preposterously attempting to pin on
Trump and his lawyers what's sad is not
even that she will now face probation
and pay a fine and write a letter
apologizing to the state and potentially
testify against the remaining defendants
up to and including potentially the
former president and current GOP front
runner what is really sad is the
disgusting regime that we are living
under we have long complained about
unjust laws and the two-tiered system of
justice and the creeping corruption
pervading the whole system certainly the
liberal
Elite but we have now reached the stage
of stalinesque show
trials the political opposition
prosecuted on bogus charges and made to
cry in front of a courtroom and on the
big state-backed media and beg
forgiveness for the egregious sin
of being a lawyer and representing a
client a client who at the time was the
duly elected sitting president of the
United States and who now would dare to
run against the current occupant of that
office what's really sad about the show
trial of my friend Jenna Ellis is not
even that this is how this whole sorry
spectacle is ending what's really sad is
that Jenna's coerced struggle session is
only the beginning I'm Michael nolles
this is the Michael nlls
Show
[Music]
welcome back to the show a young man has
gone viral for criticizing Hillary
Clinton to her face and raising
questions about Hillary's
warmongering and obviously that man has
been placed on suicide watch so we'll
get to that in one second first though a
lot has happened over the last 24 hours
especially on Capitol Hill a lot and
absolutely nothing have both somehow
simultaneously happened on Capitol
Hill Byron Donalds is a young
conservative you know he's he's only
been in Congress since getting elected
in 2020 he's uh quite right-wing uh
popular with the conservative more Trump
leaning faction of the GOP he threw his
hat back in the ring to run for speaker
after Jim Jordan ended his speaker
campaign after Steve scales ended his
speaker campaign after Kevin McCarthy
was kicked out as Speaker by Matt Gates
and a handful of conservative
Republicans and the
Democrats chip Roy who's a great
conservative member of Congress he
endorsed Byron Donald's but then Byron
didn't manage to secure the GOP
nomination to become speaker there were
a bunch of good candidates for that
nomination bunch of solid conservatives
and instead of nominating one of those
conservatives the GOP conference in the
house decided to nominate Tom emmer
who's a big squish Tom emmer is this
Republican who is on leadership track
who is
absolutely I'm not saying he's the
single worst choice that the Republicans
could have picked but he's not far from
it he was able to secure the op
nomination for speaker on the fifth
secret ballot in a Faceoff against
representative Mike Johnson who's a
Louisiana Republican who is way more
conservative than emmer and who is all
around a pretty solid
pick Tom emmer last December voted to
codify quote unquote same-sex marriage
into law Tom
emmer not that long ago this wasn't 5
years ago this wasn't 10 years ago
obviously Tom em just 10 months ago
voted for a bill so egregiously liberal
on an issue so profoundly fundamental to
politics the nature of marriage that
Barack Obama at the beginning of his
second term might not have voted for it
Tom EMR decides that he wants to be the
speaker of the house with Republicans
like Tom emmer who needs Democrats and
with Republicans like the ones who voted
for him to be the speaker Choice who
needs a republican majority in the house
so emmer gets the nomination this is all
happening Yesterday by the way then
Donald Trump who is the leader of the
Republican Party whether people like it
or not he comes out and he says that Tom
emmer stinks so he says I have many
wonderful friends wanting to be Speaker
of the House some are truly great
warriors Rhino Tom emmer who I do not
know well is not one of them he never
respected the power of a trump
endorsement of course Trump immediately
makes it about himself not about the
Rhino part he makes it about Trump he
goes he never respected the power of a
trump endorsement or the breath and
scope of Maga make Amer America great
again very true uh he fought me all the
way and actually spent more time
defending ilhan Omar than he did me he's
totally out of touch with Republican
voters that's true I believe he has now
learned his lesson because he is saying
that he is pro Trump all the way but who
can ever be sure so true there are a lot
of people who hated Trump in 16 and they
liked him or pretended to like him in
2020 and now they hate him again uh so
who could ever be sure has he only
changed because that's what it takes to
win the Republican Party cannot take
that chance because that's not where the
America First voters are vot for a
globalist rhino like Tom em would be a
tragic mistake absolutely right Trump
was correct here even if Trump was
correct for the wrong reasons and I'm
not saying he was he may have been
correct for the right reasons and
certain selfish reasons but even if he
were correct for the wrong reasons he
still made the right call in the end
which is often the case with Donald
Trump he said Tom Emer doesn't like me
so I don't like him I say Tom Emmer's a
big squish so I don't like him to be the
speaker nominee either way we've arrived
at the same conclusion and it turns out
the GOP conference did as well because
no sooner was Tom Emer nominated to be
the house candidate for speaker then he
was booted out of it he dropped out of
the race because he didn't have the
votes so then what happens well all
within the span of about 24 hours we now
have a speaker
nominee and just when things were
looking terrible for the conservatives
just when it looked like Matt Gates's
political career was over because he
booted out Kevin McCarthy who was way
better than Tom Emer who was better than
having no speaker whatsoever just when
things were looking totally Bleak array
of Hope showed up which we'll get to in
a second first though when you want to
hire people whether for the speaker of
the house or just for your own company
you got to check out Z recruiter right
now go to ziprecruiter.com we do things
differently here at the dailywire we
host several of the top news podcasts in
the world we launched a chocolate
company overnight we just took Disney
head on by releasing 100 episodes of
kids content it takes very specific
people people with very specific skills
acquired over a very long career to make
the daily wire what it is how do we find
and hire these people with zip recruiter
that's how SI recruiter makes your whole
hiring process faster and easier their
powerful technology works for you to
identify people whose skills and
experience match your job zip recruiter
saves you Time by letting you easily
invite top candidates to apply for your
job so they're more likely to apply
sooner Z recruiter is trusted by over
3.8 million businesses for their hiring
needs make a positive impact on your
hiring future with zi recruiter four out
of five employers who post on zi
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day go to ziprecruiter.com to
try zi recruiter for free that is
ziprecruiter.com
klees zi recruiter the smartest way to
hire I think now we're on our 57th
speaker candidate for the Republicans
something like that I think at least
half of my colleagues have been
nominated and lost at this I don't know
at what point do I I think I might be
nomin I may have already been nominated
and with I who knows it's happening so
fast but finally we've got a speaker
nominee who's pretty good Mike
Johnson think about just the amazing
back and forth here you have Kevin
McCarthy who's not great but he's better
than recent Republican speakers and he's
certainly more conservative than guys
like Tom emmer then they boot out
McCarthy and who do we get we get Steve
scales who's also kind of squishy and
not particularly conservative well
that's no good but then we get who do we
get we get Jim Jordan Jim Jordan's great
love Jim Jordan very conservative solid
guy but then he doesn't have the vote so
then who do we get we get maybe Byron
Donald's we get maybe Bergman we get
maybe this guy okay now we get Tom Emer
that's terrible now we get Mike Johnson
Mike Johnson is really solid he is a
Christian Conservative Republican he is
pretty rock ribbed as far as I can tell
on all of the issues uh so he would be a
good choice We will see if he gets
the actual votes that it takes to become
speaker with Tom emmer there were all
sorts of red flags but the biggest one
to me was his vote for codifying into
law this radical Preposterous
redefinition of marriage that says that
marriage is not as it has always been
for all of human history a union between
a man and a woman but it is now because
some liberal says so a union between two
guys or two women or a man and a woman
or soon enough three dudes in a billy
goat and
that's a big red flag because while the
squish Republicans say oh who cares it's
a social issue how does it affect you
you know just get stop mind your own
business who cares about
that people who have ever thought
seriously about politics for even 30
seconds recognize that the fundamental
social
institution probably has an effect on
politics that the
Bedrock Atomic unit of society
which is the
family the definition of the family the
nature of the family probably has some
effect on politics and if Kevin McCarthy
voted against redefining marriage Kevin
McCarthy and don't even just tell me
that it's because Tom emmer represents a
liberal District he doesn't he
represents a conservative district Kevin
McCarthy is from a liberal State Kevin
McCarthy is from California and yet
Kevin McCarthy the supposedly awful
squishy establishment
Rhino liberal he knows what marriage is
voted with the conservatives on marriage
Tom emmer voted against
it and I suspect the reason Tom emmer
voted against defending marriage and
voted in favor of radically redefining
it is because he like so many Beltway
people think that the wave of social
liberalism is impossible to
oppose and it's just a messy issue and
look we all have a gay cousin and so we
don't want to be mean to our gay friends
and we think it's somehow cruel to tell
people the truth about a fundamental
institution and and so can we just
ignore it and it's it's been decided
let's move
on we heard the same thing about
abortion in roie Wade from the same kind
of squishy Republicans they said oh it's
a messy issue and if you if you defend
babies in the womb you're being cruel to
women If you defend the real meaning of
marriage you're being cruel to people
who have Divergent sexual desires it's a
lie in both cases to defend innocent
life in the womb and outside the womb is
not cruel to women it's compassionate
and charitable because it's truthful
because babies are babies and we know
it's wrong to kill
them defending the traditional meaning
of marriage what marriage re actually
means is not cruel to anybody it's not
cruel to people who have Divergent
sexual views it's charitable it's
compassionate because it's truthful
you're not saying you want to take gay
guys and throw them off rooftops you're
just saying hey man marriage has a
meaning and it it can't be changed
changed because it speaks
to something that is fundamental to
human nature and certainly fundamental
to society because men and women are
different and
complimentary that the union between a
man and a woman is special and it's
different than the union between two men
and two women those unions whatever they
are they're not the same thing because
men and women are
different that's compassionate if you
believe that it is compassionate to tell
men who
are that they're if if you can at least
side with the conservatives on
the then it is a if you follow that
instinct to its logical conclusion you
have to side with the conservatives on
marriage because the point is the same
the basic point in both cases is men and
women are different this issue is not
going anywhere just because Anthony
Kennedy wrapped poetic when he was
sitting on the Supreme Court and he
wrote ODS in Supreme Court decisions
about the constitutional right to
intimacy that we all have man you know
with the universe and The Vibes uh that
doesn't change anything and and the
issue is not going to go away just as
roie Wade didn't take the issue of
abortion off the table of political
debate so too o berell and this
ridiculous Act passed by Congress with
the approval of Tom emmer it's not going
to take marriage off the table because
marriage is
fundamental can you imagine the hubris
can you imagine the pride of thinking
that the the fundamental institution
that has endured for all of human
history everywhere on Earth can just be
changed willy-nilly overnight by a
handful of wacky liberals mostly on the
Supreme Court and some others in the
Beltway and then there will just be no
push back and that's it can you imagine
the Hubris in fact we can because we see
this kind of huus and pride come from
Washington politicians all the time but
it doesn't make it real now speaking of
love and marriage and the baby carriage
there's a new study
out that shows you the reality of mass
migration you know we've dealt with mass
migration for something like 70 years
now and it just keeps increasing over
time I remember a few years ago when we
were rening our garments and nashing our
teeth because there were 2,000 illegal
aliens crossing the border every day
that was such a record high we were so
shocked by that and then the number
crept up to 2500 3,000 3500 well now
here are the numbers over the last 12
months the Biden Administration has
welcomed at least one economic migrant
into the United States for
every newborn baby in the United States
for every one new baby born in the US
you get one New Economic migrant not
some poor woman fleeing persecution not
someone seeking political Asylum not a
little dyed Dreamer
we're talking just plain regular old
often fighting age often male economic
migrants coming into the country one for
every newborn baby one for every high
school graduate in the United
States the Liberals always talk about a
conspiracy theory called the Great
replacement and they say that the
Republicans are pedling a conspiracy
theory called the Great replacement and
it's a white supremacist neonnazi racist
this is stst and I can't quite tell what
does that mean
does it mean that the policy of mass
migration is being used to displace the
current population and because of
declining cratering birth rates among
the native population in fact replace
the native population with foreigners
from other
countries how how how could you call
that a conspiracy theory in the face of
this study and so many other studies
like it that's just an empirical
fact foreigners are replacing the native
born population of the United States and
this isn't happening merely accidentally
it's happening as a matter of policy
from the very top of the US government
when Joe Biden says come across that
border even when he sometimes
contradicts himself and he says oh we're
going to build a wall we got to take
care of this but they're not actually
doing that and sometimes they're
explicit about it they say come across
that border yes flood in diversity is
our strength We're a nation of
immigrants we don't borders don't work
walls are cruel don't come on no human
being is illegal you're all future
Americans you're all dreamers in fact we
are going to ignore the Constitution
this is Barack Obama admitting this
we'll ignore the Constitution and just
give you the right to stay in the
country this is an intentional
policy and they brag about it but then
when you observe it and you cite
statistics and you look at all the
scientific studies you're a crazy
conspiracy theorist white supremacist
racist Nazi I don't know whatever
speaking of babies
a lot of people aren't having babies
these days because they want to have
dogs instead and I'm not a big dog
person I'm more of a people person but
if you do have a dog you do have a pet I
want to make sure that you're taking
care of that pet you're giving that pet
the very best food which is why you got
to check out Ruff greens right now go to
Ruff greens.com you know you know I'm
not I'm not a dog person but I am a
people person and I care for all living
creatures so I send my step brother Ruff
greens for his little Australian
Shepherd I the miniature Australian
shepherd and uh cuz I I I don't trust my
step brother to get him the good stuff
and Ru greens is the absolute best stuff
out there naturopathic doctor Dennis
black the founder of Ruff greens is
focused on improving the health of every
dog in America dog food may as well be
considered dead food since it contains
very little nutritional value let rough
greens bring your dogs food back to life
rough greens is a supplement that
contains all the necessary vitamins
minerals probiotics Omega oils digestive
enzymes and antioxidants that your dog
needs you don't have to go out and buy
new dog food you just need to
sprinkle rough Greens on their dog food
every day dog owners everywhere are
raving about rough greens it supports
healthy joints improves bad breath
boosts energy levels and so much more
head on over right now and get a free
jump start trial bag so your dog can try
it get a free jump start trial bag
deliver it straight to your door in just
a few days go to Ruff greens.com or call
844 ru F f123 that is rffg greens.com or
call 844
rf123 today folks October is almost over
there's no hiding it pumpkin spice
season is upon us and I have always been
fully embracing and living the PSL
lifestyle now you can too you go to
dailywire.com
shop get your hands on the limited
edition Michael nolles pumpkin spice
candle it's everything you need to
complete the trifecta and eat drink and
breathe pumpkin spice let me fill your
nostrils with my cinnamon vanilla
goodness don't wait order your candles
now they're only available during
pumpkin spice season you want to try to
order these in March you're out of luck
pal they're only available at
dailywire.com
shop wow it's nice
speaking of babies there is a meme going
around and it's a meme from a protest
it's a real picture it was a real
photograph that was taken and it was one
of these Pro Palestine marches and the
the banner that these protesters in the
streets were holding says reproductive
Justice Means free
Palestine and everyone's making fun of
this they're saying what does that have
to do with anything what does support
for abortion have to do with supporting
Hamas a lot of these
protests don't seem to make a lot of
sense like queers for Palestine you've
got these decadent LGBT Elemento people
with crazy colored hair who do all sorts
of weird sex stuff and they're saying
that they support Palestine while if
they were ever actually to visit
Palestine they would be hurled from the
top of a roof that doesn't seem to make
a lot of sense right that's completely
crazy but this one does make sense to me
in fact this is the only one that makes
sense to me because reproductive Justice
is a euphemism for killing babies
innocent little babies in the womb and
free Palestine 999 times out of a
thousand is just a euphemism for support
Hamas terrorists who Target civilians so
in both cases we're talking about
targeting and killing innocent people
that's all that means so of course that
makes sense of course these two groups
agree with one another similar to how
people were scratching their heads when
BLM came out and supported Hamas they
didn't just support Palestine they
didn't just oppose Zionism and the
historical development of the naan state
of Israel or anything like that they
they openly supported Hamas with
pictures of paragliders the kind of
people who landed at that music festival
and killed civilians and they said we we
stand with
Palestine why because the argument that
BLM is making is that America is an
oppressive colonial power and we need a
total Rebellion to unseat the settlers
and the colonizers from Power that's
what they say usually in those exact
words and what's the argument for the
pro Palestine pramas side they say
Israel is a colonial power established
by the British Empire much like America
was and their oppressors and their
settlers and their colonizers and we
need a total Revolution to eradicate all
of them and and not just eradicate an
ideology by the way but but eradicate
actual people from this territory so
it's it's the exact same
argument that that is being made by BLM
of course there is some agreement there
and of course people who think it's fine
to kill innocent little babies in the
womb of course they they're going to
think it's fine to kill civilians in a
time of War they're not going to think
twice about it now speaking of killing
civilians Hillary Clinton was just
giving a talk at the Institute for
Global politics and she was Fielding
questions I suppose and one Brave young
man stood up to question Hillary's
warmongering can you please make a
statement about President Joe Biden's
speech this is a clearly warmongering
speech President Joe Biden is calling
for a hundred billion dollar of funding
for Israel Taiwan and Ukraine and we're
supposed to just bundle these together
and pretend like we're going to rush to
World War II and we're all just going to
let Hillary rodam Clinton sit here okay
I'm sorry you know this is not this is
not the way to have a conversation
conversation you're welcome to come talk
to me can sit here okay right you're
you're going to you're going to wait for
me right please I don't I do not believe
you I listen to you and I will respond I
do not believe you respectfully I do not
believe you the fact of the matter is
that the American people's voice are
what need to be heard because because
our president is not speaking for the
American people and neither are you
that's your opinion that's your opinion
yes that's my opinion but well then sit
down we've heard your opinion thank you
very much for once I actually believe
Hillary this this man seems incredulous
that Hillary will stick around and wait
for him
afterwards I think she's going to wait
for him I think she's this man is
definitely going to see Hillary again
you know I'm really sorry to hear about
this man's imminent suicide seems like a
nice enough fella a little bit excitable
a little bit eccentric
but she they're going to talk soon and
there might not be much talking actually
in that
conversation I sometimes wonder how I've
survived Hillary all these years I think
it's because I've I've mentioned this on
the show before but not recently Hillary
and I are cousins in-law on my
great-grandmother's side on my paternal
great-grandmother's side uh we've got
I've got a relative who married into the
rodom family and so Hillary is a sort of
cousin of mine and I I think it's merely
because of family ties that she has not
just shown up yet in the middle of the
night you know with a mustache on her
maybe just a full ski mask and just put
that pillow over my head snuffed out me
in this entire show thankful I'm
grateful to Hillary for that uh this man
however does not seem to have any ties
of kinship with Hillary and so I'm not
sure that he'll be so lucky in any case
what does this mean here what it means
politically is that the Democrats are
now the party of
War when I was growing up up 20 years
ago Republicans were the party of War
Republicans were the party of going in
and bomb in the Middle East and they
often had Democrats support in those
Endeavors but the Democrats had
plausible deniability because George W
Bush was the president and they could
say oh Bush lied and he tricked us and
we actually would have opposed the war
had we known now the Democrats were the
anti-war party and the Republicans were
the pro-war party that has completely
flipped just like a lot has flipped in
politics since I was a kid when I was a
kid Republicans they were the party of
the big fat cat they were the party of
Wall Street party of Rich Uncle
pennybags Democrats were the party of
the working man that has completely
flipped now Republicans are the party of
the deplorable irredeemable Blue Collar
disgusting low class worker whatever
sort of things Hillary would call them
and Democrats they're the party of oh
the Ivory Tower and the cocktail party
set and Wall Street and big business it
was a huge flip when I was a kid
Republicans were the party of free trade
and globalization Democrats largely were
the party of economic protection and
skepticism toward free trade Bill
Clinton signed a big free trade deal but
a lot of Democrats were very skeptical
of free trade that's totally flipped now
Republicans are the party of protection
which is a return to a more traditional
Republican view the Republican party in
fact was founded on tariffs Abraham
Lincoln was a major proponent of
economic protection and tariffs
Democrats were much more in favor of
free trade things change and a lot of
people respond to this by saying that
it's hypocrisy it's not sometimes it is
hypocrisy sometimes it is but a lot of
times it is not a lot of times it is
because politics is about applying
Eternal principles to changing
circumstances and so in certain
political circumstances a a little more
uh trade might be a good thing a little
loosening up of economic controls might
be a good thing in other circumstances
though it might not be
it's not always hypocrisy here U however
it is in in the case of peace and War
this does seem to be a more significant
shift than should we open up the trade a
little bit or should we increase the
tariffs a little bit this is a
recognition that the Democrats are now
the hegemonic political power in the
United States maybe that's been the case
for a long time and we just didn't
notice it but the Democrats now having
amassed power in virtually every single
sector of the country the one area where
they didn't have total hegemony was in
the military and even there you can see
the top brass has gone totally woke Mark
Millie whining about white rage and and
promoting critical race Theory as the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
they seem to have even the military as
well and with that hegemonic power
you're going to see a much more
willingness to flex that power and so on
the domestic front you're going to get
show trials like we saw with Jenna Ellis
and the the tearful forced confession
and overseas you were going to get war
war and more war and and the protesters
the the sincere protesters the ones who
are actually dissidents in our country
they're going to tend to be on the right
now speaking of liberal women who want
to be
president we've got a thousand
candidates for Speaker of the House
we've got uh little less than that for
president of the United States we might
get a new candidate for president and
that would be Liz Cheney if it came down
to it even though you disagree with Joe
Biden on almost every issue Under the
Sun other than maybe Ukraine and Israel
would you vote for him over Donald Trump
we're going to see what what happens
we're going to see how things unfold I
think Donald Trump is the single most
dangerous threat we face I would imagine
that there will be a number of other
candidates in the race um would you be
one of them I think I'll tell you what
I'm what I am definitely going to do I'm
going to spend the next uh year between
now and the election certainly helping
to elect serious people helping to elect
sane people
um to Congress of both parties yes we
don't want a situation where the
election is thrown into the House of
Representatives and Donald Trump has any
possibility at all of prevailing under
those circumstances so we've got to
elect people who believe in the
Constitution and who take their
responsibility seriously to Congress so
I'm going to be spending a lot of time
doing that in addition to other things
but you're not ruling out a presidential
run no I'm
not M Chen has been trying to Jin up a
presidential run for a long time sort of
like the the girl and Mean Girls who's
trying to make the word f happen it's
not going to happen no one there's not
going to be a major Rally For Liz we're
ready for Liz it's Janie time you know
what we need now Cheney as president
yeah that's not going to happen my
response to that is LOL she says I'm
going to elect serious people sane
people whenever you hear Republicans
using that kind of language it is a
euphemism for electing Democrats well
look I'm not I'm not a turncoat I'm not
a squish I'm not betraying what I
profess to be my beliefs and my
constituents I no I'm just I just think
these Republicans have gone insane there
there have been these sorts of political
ads going all the way back to the Barry
Goldwater campaign you I am I'm a
republican all my life but this
Goldwater man he's totally crazy so I'm
going to only vote for Democrats now uh
you you hear it all the time and you're
hearing it today from Liz Cheney these
are these are people who give proof Pro
of what is called the uni party Jake
Tapper says you'll you'll elect people
of both parties yeah sure as long as
they're going to stop that Donald Trump
because that crazy Donald Trump he wants
to stop Mass migration he wants to stop
Perpetual War he wants
to bring manufacturing back to the
United States he wants us to be
self-sufficient and not just debt slaves
to China he wants us to be normal he
wants us to live according to an
ordinary American life and he wants to
make the country great again we can't
have that so I'll elect anybody my
number one priority is preventing that
from happening and I'll elect Democrats
and I'll elect Republicans but I'm
mostly going to elect Democrats because
that's what side they're on right now so
she says she's going to maybe run for
president the 2024 primary I think comes
down largely to a denial of
reality some people occasionally on the
show have accused me of sing for Donald
Trump for for not attacking Donald Trump
enough for frequent enough or being too
positive about his chances of becoming
the
nominee and I I sometimes feel that
those criticisms are shooting the
messenger because as I've said I'm not
endorsing anybody in the primary I like
Donald Trump I don't hate Donald Trump I
like him and I like Ronda santis I think
Ronda santis is a is a great candidate I
think he's a great Governor I think he
could be a good GOP nominee I like other
people in the in the race
too but I am not going to to deny the
reality that Donald Trump is almost
certainly going to be the GOP nominee
it's not impossible that someone else
could get it he could God forbid drop
dead they could just lock him up forever
like who knows but all all of the
evidence available to us says that Trump
is almost certainly going to be the
nominee and a lot of people in this
primary are denying that the main way
they deny it is by pretending that this
is just an ordinary primary it's not
you've got the former president running
for a non executive second term we
haven't seen that sort of thing in a
very long time he up like 50 points in
the polls his organization is much more
put together than the other candidates
organizations he's a global celebrity
and has been for 40 years he has already
been the president so he's got a leg up
because he can prove that he's done
certain things that have been popular he
is uncommonly charismatic in part
because he's a Hollywood
celebrity those are just facts you might
hate him you might say some other guy
would be a better president maybe the
other guy would be a better president
but that's just a reality and and one of
the guarantors that uh Donald Trump will
be the nominee if he is to be the
nominee is that everybody keeps denying
reality so all these people are sticking
in the
race the fact that these candidates who
are at one and two and 3% are still in
the race the fact that Doug beram
entertaining as he is charming as he
might be sometimes is still in the race
the fact that Liz Cheney is considering
entering into the race shows you that
the Republican party is denying
political
reality and so long as they do that the
person whom reality at the moment tends
to favor is most likely to
Prevail it's now time to bring an end to
the 18 yearlong nightmare of the case of
Steven Avery and the murder of Teresa
halbach do not miss the season finale of
convicting a murderer tomorrow you know
the story and now we're exposing the
truth Candace is finally bringing you
answers to all the questions making a
murderer created make sure you're caught
up on episodes 1-9 for the finale
tomorrow because you were not going to
want to wait to see what was uncovered
in the final episode here is a sneak
peek at the season finale coming up on
the finale of convicting a murderer how
were these filmmakers able to convince
so many people that a man like Steven
Avery is innocent the only story they
wanted to tell was one of police
corruption they were committed to a
story she's doing a good job she's doing
a lot of Investigation they were looking
into things for him doing more public
defender and my investigator they were
Steven Aver's PR team they convinced
millions of people that they were
innocent emails show that they were
providing plenty of direction that the
averies were to look like a close-knit
family man County officers were to look
suspicious I think I will forever be
obsessed with the media's ability to
turn a villain into a hero or a hero
into the villain if they could do it to
me they can do it to anybody
else
[Music]
make sure you tune in it's the last
episode of this Saga Bravo to Candace
for doing fabulous work and exposing
media lies you can binge all 10 episodes
tomorrow but only if you're a dailywire
plus member so sign up today at
dailywire.com subscribe to watch the
entire series do not miss the season
finale of convicting a murderer
tomorrow sign up today my favorite
comment yesterday is from Larry oxentine
8310 who says a church building is just
a building the church is the people it
will never be destroyed there is a lot
of Truth to that but it's not totally
true because the church is incarnational
because the faith is incarnational
because our Lord is Incarnate of the
Holy Spirit born of the Virgin Mary and
became man so yes we we we don't want to
make an idle out of physical things but
we don't want to deny the importance and
the significance of physical things our
Lord takes on flesh and dwells Among Us
I heard this a lot during
Co obviously the the more traditional uh
flavors of Christianity up up to and
including especially the Catholic Church
are place a great deal of emphasis on
physicality on sacraments on rights on
rituals on gestures on right Sacrament
being the meeting of the physical and
metaphysical and so what I heard from
some of my friends who were a little
less uh sacramentally lined who who are
Christian is they would say well look
the church isn't a place it's just you
know it's it's metaphysical thing and
yeah it's metaphysical but it's physical
too you
know what does our Lord do when he's
resurrected and he goes to see his
friends and he's standing they're all
out on the ship and he's he's out just
on the on the beach he's grilling them
fish it's like the
fleshiem eyes to heal them he breathes
on the apostles you know there's a
physical aspect here and so obviously
the comment is in response to Israel's
destruction or of part of this extremely
old church that dates back at the very
least of the 12th century and really has
roots all the way back in Antiquity in
Gaza and I said obviously the state of
Israel has a right to defend itself but
we need an explanation of why this
happened because the the want and
destruction of ancient I and religious
architecture art relics that is a very
serious thing we can't just throw our
hands in the air and say ah well the
church is metaphysical yeah it's it's
got a physical expression too in time
and space and history in fact that's
that's perhaps the defining feature of
the faith now moving on from Liz Cheney
but still speaking of blond
women Taylor Swift has turned her eras
tour it's this big tour where she went
all around the country and it was sold
out everywhere and I had The Misfortune
of Being in downtown Nashville on a
night when the concert let out and I
felt like I was in a third world country
you couldn't get a car there were a
gazillion people flooding into the
street it was Mayhem people go crazy
when Taylor Swift announced her concert
tour every woman in this office I walk
in you I show up here early I'm here
earlier than almost anybody and the
moment I come in this is the very very
beginning of the work day just as I come
in from my show all the girls are
refreshing the page to try to get the
early tickets from American people love
Taylor Swift I have never in my life
consciously intentionally listened to a
Taylor Swift song I couldn't I couldn't
name a Taylor Swift song the one I the
one exception to that is the the one
about I'm a problem it's you or I'm a
problem it's me guess that would make
more sense uh because my producers made
me listen to it to react to it on the
show but I I couldn't tell you what a
Taylor Swift song is other than that
well she turned this bestselling tour
into a movie and the movie has held the
number one spot at the box office for
the second weekend it surged well over
$100 million it's made history is the
first concert film ever across the $100
million
Mark why why I don't am I going to have
to go see this movie am I going to have
I avoided the Taylor Swift erors tour I
might have to go see
it to make Mak sense of this cultural
phenomena because I have an
inkling of why Taylor Swift does so well
I don't mean to diminish Taylor
Swift she has a lot of things to
recommend her is she Bach is she Mozart
no I don't think so is
she the greatest Lyricist or musician or
singer or dancer ever no is she the most
glamorous Hollywood star ever no is she
no and actually I think that's why she's
so
popular she's just kind of
normal and in in another
age that would be fine and she might be
popular but in our age which is so
abnormal which exalts
abnormality and bizarre things people
crave something that's normal she's just
kind of nice
looking
blond doesn't have any tattoos doesn't
have any piercings doesn't when she
makes statements about politics they're
relatively mild Center left
perfectly socially acceptable statement
acceptable to the ruling class still
basically acceptable to the
populace she sings songs about her
ex-boyfriends that's basic that's pretty
much it everyone kind that's a relatable
experience there's nothing particularly
profound in any of the songs I'm not
sure there's very much meaningful at all
in the songs but she's just kind of
normal and being kind of normal is
enough in an age that has gone
completely insane speaking of what
people want very said study came out
showing that nearly one in four adults
across the world report feeling very or
fairly lonely this is according to a
metag Gallup survey this is not just a
survey of Americans or a certain age
bracket new survey was taken across 142
countries
found that 24% of people age 15 and
older self-reported feeling very or
fairly lonely in response to the
question how lonely do you feel the
survey also found that the rates of
loneliness were highest in young people
so you might expect older people maybe
whose friends have died who have
suffered all sorts of losses lived a
little bit that they might be lonelier
no it's younger people the young people
who were supposed to be out and
constantly around other young people and
going on dates and just surrounded by
social life they report being the
loneliest 27% of young adults aged 19 to
29 report feeling very or fairly lonely
and the the lowest rates were actually
found in older adults only 177% of
people aged 65 and older reported
feeling lonely why is this why is
everybody so lonely part of it is that
we are living in that uh how does it
affect you culture what we were talking
about the very top of the show the
culture which says ignore social
questions ignore any uh need for
consensus any agreement on anything in
society how does it affect you let
people do whatever decadent Divergent
depraved things they want to do just you
do you and I'll do me and we'll we'll
just do different things well a
consequence of that is we're going to be
more isolated we're not going to have as
much in common and we're not going to
have as much to say to one another and
we're not going to we're going to feel
alienated that's part of it but at a
deeper level why are people lonely at a
deeper level the loneliness pandemic
is directly attributable to the decline
and sidelining of virtue it comes down
to that because true friendship is only
possible among virtuous people Good Old
Uncle Aristotle told us this Millennia
ago there there are three kinds of
friendship we could say friendship of
pleasure you know we both like meatballs
and
martinis friendships of
utility which is we we can help each
other professionally
say and friendships of virtue where
people who are basically good who
practice virtue and TT down Vice spend
time with one another because they're
both oriented toward the good and
working toward the good and when you are
oriented toward and looking working
toward the good you get happier and when
you're oriented toward and doing things
that are bad you get less
happy there's a good book by Alistair
McIntyre a a still living philosopher
called after virtue a highly recommended
book because it it talks about this very
problem we have sidelined virtue we've
forgotten about virtue many people in
our culture mock the notion of virtue
and they say it's
illusory and and that's bad and if you
if you don't care about virtue at all
you might end up in Hell someday you're
going to have probably a miserable life
you're going to fall into bad habits
you're going to do all sorts of things
but one of the least discussed aspects
of that is you're going to have a harder
time making friends I'm not saying that
if you are lonely right now it's because
you are not virtuous it's a social
problem if you live in in a just if
living in a culture that denies and
Sidelines virtue is going to greatly
increase the chances that you're going
to be lonely and have troubl making
friends because it's a social problem
it's not just about what you do it's
about what everybody does but then there
it is there's the answer to that
question how does it affect you how does
it affect you if we pass some law well
because the law is a teacher and it it
molds the populace just as education
molds children well how does it affect
you it affects me because I live in a
society and when you pass laws and when
you have rituals and culture that is
going to warp the the the fabric in
which I move the fabric of the space in
which I move and that is going to create
a certain kind of society and that
affects me a lot the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
become a member use code NES KW has a
checkout for 2 months free on all annual
plans
[Music]
a